the chances of the saints to be the
number one seed may be broken as a
result of that loss to the philadelphia
eagles here is saints coach sean payton
from earlier today taking responsibility
for the unexpected loss to the eagles on
the road
you know when you talk about uh
preparation and you know yesterday you
started mentioning that you know the
team may not have been prepared is that
mostly just game planning and steaming
or some of that
no listen don't don't listen to what i'm
saying all right i didn't say the team
ever wasn't prepared i said man we
looked flat we didn't look ready to play
and that's a reflection on me and that's
it's upsetting
and so i've got to do a better job of
making sure i don't i don't think we
played well in any phase
i'm watching it again right now
offensively it's sloppy screens the
naked the run game
it looks awful
and defensively
they're still running
you know the quarterbacks outside the
pocket
all the things
we didn't want to allow happen happen in
that game
we can't kick a field goal early in the
game two weeks in a row
that's a problem so
that's where we start
i like it when a head coach takes
responsibility for the failure of his
team to be in the right mindset ready to
go because it is the coach's
responsibility to make sure that the
players are ready to go he has to press
the buttons he has to say and not say
the things necessary to get his guys
ready and it didn't work and now the
saints find themselves tied with the
green bay packers who are prone to some
periodic lapses and some flat
performances but the packers 10-3 the
saints 10-3 packers holding the one seed
by virtue of the head-to-head tiebreaker
against the saints way back in week
three that's for those early season
games
matter the most the teams change
dramatically from september but those
wins in september number one their money
in the bank number two
they may set you up for that tiebreaker
advantage when january rolls around
shireen and they have taken a hit to
their chances to be the number one seed
steve cornett had all the statistics and
percentages last night on football night
in america and you can see what that
loss to the saints does and what the win
by the packers does it reduces
significantly the saints chances of
being the one seed
yeah the first time in the last two
seasons mike that they've lost with
their backup quarterback 5-0 last season
with teddy bridgewater 3-1 this season
with taysom hill but here's the funny
thing mike so i was doing a google
search i wanted to see what the locals
were saying about you know sean payton
taking responsibility for the law so i
put in the keywords in a google search
you know what i found and completely
forgot about this completely slipped my
mind almost the exact same story last
year and i'd forgotten this they lost to
the one in eight falcons 26-9 and sean
payton said after the game i take full
responsibility for this loss i didn't
have my team prepared for the game we
came out flat
same exact words that he said after that
game in 2019 so i tell you what i'm
gonna look at the schedule in 2021 and
when they have what i think is a really
bad team that they're going to play in
2021 i'm going to pick them to lose that
game so that's two years in a row now
they've done something similar
and you can have the quotes ready you
can put the quotes out before he even
says them that's right it's amazing that
he's got a card this is the card that he
goes to in the event of a late season
loss to a team they should beat you just
read off the card this is what i do and
then everything will be fine but they
are they are prone to playing poorly
early in the season and then having kind
of a random stinker late in the season
when it looks like they're otherwise in
good shape then people start to doubt
them then they find the gas pedal again
and then they get to the playoffs and
they have their hearts ripped out and
shown to them at some point before they
actually get back to the super bowl
that's the way it's gone for the saints
since 2017. but the bottom line is they
are going to have their work cut out for
them to force the road to the super bowl
through the super dome and to get a week
off
come
what will be the wild card round because
only one team per conference gets it now
and the packers have the inside track
and for the packers i think the big test
is the titans in week 16.
and they'll know if the saints hold
serve the next two weeks because the
saints play the vikings on christmas day
if the saints win that game that's a ton
of pressure shireen on the packers to
take care of the titans who are going to
be playing for their own
playoff positioning when that sunday
night rolls around coming up in just a
couple of weeks
and you know aaron rodgers talked about
that yesterday really how important home
field advantage is from the simple fact
that he hasn't had it the championship
games they've played it have been on the
road and yes there's not going to be
fans there but they would love to have
it and they all would love to have that
first round buy and i think it's
important that they get it and so
there's going to be a ton of pressure on
these two teams as they fight this out
the last three weeks and you know
normally that last week you you play
your reserves a little bit and rest your
starters if you can i don't know if
that's going to be the case this year i
think they're both going to have
something to play for and that's going
to be that first round buy and home
field throughout the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports